ich will was sagen zum typischen profil
solcher mütter wohlbemerkt das sind
daten aus vielen verschiedenen fällen
auf der ganzen welt teilweise auch in
den usa und das sind sozusagen meter
studien wissenschaftliche meter studien
die quasi alle fälle die bekannt sind
betrachten und daraus eine art
durchschnitts profil machen
ich will dass einmal durchgehen und ich
sehe einige punkte die hier zu treffen
aber auch einige die nicht zutreffen und
einige bei denen ich keine ahnung habe
ob sie zu treffen also es ist kein
psychogramm zu ihr wenn sie so wollen
sondern eher das durchschnittliche
psychogramm und man muss schauen was
davon zu trifft häufig sind mütter die
diese taten begehen ende 20 das trifft
in jedem falls du sie kommen oft aus
ärmeren verhältnissen haben selbst
gewalt oder missbrauchserfahrungen
häufig findet man depressionen oder
selbstmord tendenzen sehr typisch ist
auch dass sie kurz vorher eine trennung
durch leben also die amerikaner sagen
experience rejection bei mayweather also
zurückweisung durch einen männlichen
partner oder ex-partner sie hat mal auf
facebook gepostet der mann ist weg und
jetzt hat noch die wohnung gebrannt das
kommt aber aus 2014
das scheint hier nicht aber wir haben
auch gerade von dem polizeieinsatz
gehört wo es auch um die gedanken gingen
damals bei dem vater der jüngeren kinder
also anscheinend doch auch probleme in
der beziehung mit dem partner absolute
aber die trennung liegt schon länger
zurück also die trennung scheint hier
zumindest nicht der direkte auslöser zu
sein
sie nutzen eher die leisen worten
manchmal findet man ebenfalls drogen
oder alkoholmissbrauch typischerweise
sehen sie die kinder wie eine art
erweiterung von sich selbst sie sehen
die kinder gar nicht als getrennte
individuellen sondern im grunde
vermischen sie ihr eigenes selbstbild
und ihre persönlichkeit mit den kindern
das heißt wenn sie geht dass die kinder
mit kommen ist dann sozusagen gar keine
gar keine frage oft sozial isoliert
wenig kontakte das gilt für die kinder
und auch die mütter keine hilfe von
außen alleinerziehend und in 50 bis 60
prozent der fälle geht der philly zieht
der mord an den kindern mit suizid oder
einem suizidversuch einher
wenn ich dieses typische profil mir
anschaue was der aktuelle stand der
forschung ist dann sehe ich einige
punkte die zu treffen
zu vielen kann man noch nicht sagen und
man muss natürlich auch erstmal mit ihr
sprechen und ihr auch die chance geben
das zu erklären und auch die frage
stellen ob sie überhaupt diese gedanken
nicht geschildert habe ob sie die
bewusst getroffen hat oder ob es andere
psychische erkrankungen gibt und ob sie
überhaupt schuldfähig
in wiefern sie das reflektiert hat das
gilt es noch abzuwarten und der
pressesprecher der polizei hat ja auch
gesagt dass man erst mal mit ihr
sprechen muss bevor man hier valide was
zum motiv sagen kann